joining us Cottonelle entire coaches
corner the new Tennessee Titans head
coach he's Mike Vrabel from The Ohio
State University coach how are you this
morning
I'm wonderful how are you Dan I'm doing
spectacular how would you describe your
coaching style for those who aren't
aware of it
I mean I'm energetic I'm honest
compassionate fair loyal but I'm a lot
of things based on what what I feel is
best for the player I'm hands-on you
[Music]
know you just try to look when you try
to coach and you try to make somebody
better you look at who they are you look
at what what their personality is and
you try to do everything you can to
improve the player improve the person
and you treat everybody the same way no
no I think you treat everybody fairly
but you have to treat everybody
differently because people are going to
learn differently they're going to
respond differently and they're going to
you know they all have a different
skillset everybody is different and that
wouldn't be any fun if everybody was the
same what is the one trait I must have
if I'm going to play for you just a love
football you have to love to be able to
grind you have to have a grit you have
to love your teammates to put the team
first and you have to love to have fun
and to be able to not take yourself so
seriously and be able to laugh at
yourself and that's what's beautiful
about a locker room
everybody comes together from different
places and you form a team and it
doesn't happen the first week of the
second week it happens over time begin
to trust people so it's pretty cool to
be able to do that I loved your opening
press conference with Tennessee I mean
you you were it wasn't like Belichick
that's for sure you didn't take any tips
from Belichick at a press conference
that's for sure no I mean I think we
come across that I mean we come across a
lot of people in our lives and if we pay
attention and focus we can learn things
from everybody we can learn things that
we want to do that we liked how they do
we're going to do it that way or we can
learn that we don't like it and I
wouldn't do it that way so you try to
take things from everybody that you come
across and if you just pay time and
asked our players to pay attention and
focus and try to learn something from
every coach every support staff and our
building going to have great people in
place in our building that are going to
help our players do their jobs whether
that be from the people in the cafeteria
to people in the weight room to the
equipment managers you know our players
will know that their job is critical and
they'll fake them for what they do for
our players when's the last time you put
on money or Super Bowl rings a long long
time they were still they were stoned
they were stolen in Houston our house
was broken into and they were stolen and
all three all three and you know to me I
think that the only people that really
want to wear those things are the ones
that have never worn them or never won
them once you win it and it's about the
players it's about the people and the
coaches you don't need a to wear a ring
when you get a champion you're gonna get
replacements no I don't know when y'all
what do I need what do I need a
replacement for you know I mean
everybody knows that the Patriots won
the Super Bowl in 2001 in 2003 and 2004
yeah and they all know that I was on
that team so I'm I wouldn't wear him you
know I wouldn't know that's a shame I'm
not that's not what I'm about I'm not
about that
I don't want our players to to want to
win a championship so you get a ring I
want to win a championship because of
the experiences and the relationships
that you build when guys like Richard
Seymour and Willy McGuinness and Rodney
Harrison and Tedy Bruschi and Roman
Pfeiffer send you texts and you see them
and they congratulate you and they call
you and that's why that's what I wanted
to win a championship for you know it's
a shame that somebody stole those we're
talking to Mike Vrabel Titans head coach
joining us Continental Tire Coach's
Corner your favorite Tom Brady's story
you know somebody asked me that and I
think in pre-season someone did a story
so I went down they said hey you're
gonna play tight end I said okay sweet
what do I do they said study these plays
and you know get open and catch the ball
and we're practice and I must have come
what I felt like was open
you know I'm yelling and waving my arms
Tommy Tommy Tommy and I come back to the
huddle and I'm a second you know what's
going on and he said Mikey if you ever
yell my name again I will never show you
the effing ball again I said okay good
shape but he did throw it to you twelve
times I mean you have no other choice
no other choice okay explain this to me
though coach at what point does the
defense go over Abel's in the game and
he's got eight touchdown receptions and
he's been targeted
eight times like how did people not
realize rables in the game he's probably
getting the ball well there's other
plays you know I think that that's what
people don't realize is that there's
actually other plays than the one where
I went out for a pass we ran the ball in
when I was in there we were not behind
me of course but we ran it we ran routes
where I was covered or people you know
whatever and we threw the other guys
Daniel Graham scored we threw to Tom
Ashworth was an offensive tackle he
scored Heath Evans score we threw passes
a Christian for you and all these other
tight ends and every mean guys scored
and you know then they then then when I
was open or the route was there
that's where Tom threw it I can't
believe that you'd actually say Tommy
honey I'm open no I just thought yeah
when you're open I saw Randy Moss put
his hand up and you threw it to him I
think it's a little different when Randy
does it then what was the reaction you
receive when you said that college
football with Saban and Urban Meyer or
farm system for the NFL like people
reacted I think you know it was
interesting and again that was nothing
but a compliment to great coaches that I
have a lot of respect for and take
a lot of things that I do from my two
years with Urban Meyer and have met one
that's say but when we go to Alabama to
see players and watch how they run their
program and when we the point is when we
get players in in the NFL that are from
those types of programs they have been
treated as pros because they act like
pros those kids get up they prepare they
they have to do all that and go to
school and go to class and they know how
to take care of their bodies they get
treatment so the way they are coached
the way they watch film the way they
practice their performance on the field
the way they're evaluated the the
pressure of new players coming in that
are just as good that they have to try
to keep their position and prove
themselves every day all those things
that I believe in they're doing and so
and they're doing it at a high level and
so that was nothing but a compliment and
when I said we it was it wasn't a figure
of speech I know who pays or admire and
I know who pays Nick Saban but my point
was we're everybody and then FL is very
appreciative of the types of players
that come out of that program and then
there's other kids that we draft other
players that we draft that aren't from
those programs and then we have to make
sure that they're in a routine that they
know how to study that they know how to
prepare that they are lifting the right
way that they are taking care of their
bodies the right way and that's what I
met by it and I don't know how anybody
took it I'm not sure how how did you
take it oh no I said you just pull back
the curtain and told us what the truth
was it is a farm system that coaches are
well compensated but they are preparing
these guy I didn't think it was a slight
I just said no I said rebel just said
what is the truth of this and people may
have a problem with that with the truth
that's why I came away
I would I would hope that we could get
as many of those players from those
programs as we possibly could because
they're doing well at the next level and
they're very well prepared in case I run
into coach Belichick since I'm going to
the Super Bowl here and it's on NBC and
I'm hosting it what would be a good
question I could ask coach Belichick
that he wouldn't dismiss me or bark down
my throat
mmm-maybe asking about his favorite matt
cassel story what what is that favorite
I have a few you know and then now you
know I I'm Matt castles coach and so
Matt Cassel and I were teammates and
yeah and when you're Tom Brady's backup
you know that life can't be easy and so
certainly I'm sure bill had a few good
moments with Matt wait why why is it
tough being Brady's backup you want to
do anything well you play a lot of
pre-season it feels like you got some
stories here Mike and you're not you
know there we've had and that's all part
of the okay building the team that's all
part of building a team man is just
making sure that you get the right guys
in the locker room and that's that was
what I missed the most in coaching and I
remember the day that I said if being a
coach means that you can't have a great
relationship with the guys you work with
and a bond and a relationship with the
guys that you're working with I'm not
going to be able to do it because that's
what I was used to for all those years
at Ohio State and in the National
Football League I've been working on my
Belichick impersonation how's it going
hoodie cutoff no no just uh just the
voice come in here you're gonna try to
break it you're gonna break it out on
well no I've done it before I'm not
gonna do it on Super Bowl Sunday
Caliendo does a pretty good when I don't
know yeah he's probably got the best one
he just grumble and mumble but he's been
a great mentor he was it was a great
coach I can remember the day called me
and free agency offered me $225,000
signing bonus it was $75,000 left less
than I signed four years earlier as a
rookie he said you know what I think you
can be good and you're cheap and so
you're my favorite player I think you're
a pretty good football player and I
think oh yeah I can bring in your kind
of cheap you're my kind of football
player you got it now that's about how
it went down flew up there and signed
the contract
hey we'll check in with you to start a
next
I'm curious how things are gonna turn
around there or move forward I should
say and I know we're excited you know
we're excited in the process of reaching
all the players on our team and and to
let them know that I can't wait till
they get back here into the building
that's the worst part of coaching is
when you can't be around players
well coach congratulations and good luck
right there all right and that's Mike
Vrabel tunnel tonight coaches corner
from Sun to rain to snow and everything
in between Continental Tire has
engineered a tire for what you do we
should have done the Andrew Luck
impersonation well we're on a roll here
honk gonna be in the same division as
Andrew Luck ah extraordinary performance
and reliability putting confidence into
driving for more information and a
location of a dealer near you behind
Tire especially in the cold weather
Continental Tire Continental Tire
Continental Tire from what you do for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]